you guys really need to quit asking the
same questions over and over again oh
boy another Rosco J episode I bet you're
so excited cuz I know I am dailybooth
question IV Amy wants to know if I like
your mustache it's pretty cool but what
do you think about mine I want to be a
[__] asks if I used to dance even before
YouTube well actually before YouTube was
myspace and I used to dance on there all
the time
little Todd wants to know why I started
uploading videos to YouTube what is with
all these hard names I blame you Shekhar
oh and what's the best video that I've
shot on YouTube actually I'm gonna leave
that up to you guys what has been your
favorite video that I've shot so far as
for why I started uploading videos to
YouTube I was actually just bored
Twitter question Anderson H was the
first Apple product that she purchased
the first Apple product that I purchased
myself that I saved all of my money for
when I was 16 it was this Power Mac g4
it's beautiful Alex ray what's your
favorite dance move how about this one
Facebook question Adam wants to know if
I would try out for American Idol
or so you think you could dance really
with these dance skills I don't even
think so you think you can dance can
handle it because obviously I can dance
somebody's car alarm is going off
Alexia asks if I hate the word epic
actually as a matter of fact I do and
some of you people overuse it way too
much
Rachel Team Edward or Team Jacob
actually I'm gonna go with team Damon on
Vampire Diaries formspring question so
there's a new website out there called
formspring got me it's actually not that
new but I just started using it and
there's a place where people can ask you
questions and you can answer them
directly on the website so we here's
some questions from you guys I tune
graphics wants to know if I'm gonna
start including formspring questions in
my ask IJ episodes you better believe it
how many messages are in your inbox when
you log into YouTube right now it looks
like there's over 20,000 you guys are
little message senders if I went and did
relief work in Haiti what piece of
technology would I take my iPhone
question for you in the last episode I
asked you guys what you thought of the
new Heinz ketchup packets most of you
guys thought it was pretty awesome some
of you guys didn't like it some of you
didn't really even care but here's a few
of the comments that I liked
since you guys seem to love to try to
pair me up with random people on YouTube
who would you like to see me have a fake
baby with next let me know leave a
comment and I will put a picture of me
and that person in the next episode
thanks so much for watching this episode
of ask IJ and as always leave your
questions and comments and stuff and
I'll see you guys in the next episode
bye
you